تستفيق مدينه رفح جنوبيه قطاع غزه على
واقع مجزره اسرائيليه جديده ادت الى
ارتقاء نحو 17 فلسطينيا معظمه من الاطفال
والنساء كما تشاهدون هذا هو المنزل الذي
قصف من قبل الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي دون
سابق انذار بطبيعه الحال وادى ذلك الى هذا
العدد الكبير من الشهداء من الاطفال جلهم
ومن النساء كانوا نيام بطبيعه الحال في
هذا المنزل الواقع في منطقه حي الجنين
الشرقي مدينه رفح في محيط منطقه المقابر
تحديدا وادى ذلك الى هذا العدد الكبير
بينهم نازحين نزحوا من مناطق عده من قطع
غزه الى هذا المنزل كي يحتم به على امل ان
يكون هذا المكان
امن هنا حجم الدمار الكبير في المكان
ودمار ايضا منازل مجاوره من الاسبست من
الصفيح بطبيعه الحال والله نايمين في ل
الاولاد والصغار وكنا وانا عند بنتي نعم
الا ما
نص الوت طلعنا لاقينا الدنيا زي ماك بتشوف
كلياتها زي هيك دمار وكلياتهم صغار يعني
شايف وين الصاروخ لقينا هي شفته هنا في
الصاله لضمان اكبر قتل يعني من او استشهاد
اكبر عدد حاطه زارعه في الصاله عشان اللي
في الصاله واللي في الغرفه يضمن انهم كلهم
اموات كلهم يموتوا هذا اسرائيل بتقوللك
رفحه امنه وبيوت امنه واحنا الابرياء
واحنا واحنا زي ما
بتدعي زو ياتهم نسوان وصغار كم شهيد يا
حجه في المنزل انا 16 شهيد اها عيله ابني
مراته واولاده
ثلاثه وا اخوات اج على النازحين من غزه من
خن
يونس كمان كلياتهم نسوان وحوامل واولاد
صغار للعرب اللي بيشوفوش وبسمعو وللمجتمع
الدولي اللي بكلون همه اسرائيل ما بيشوف
غير المصاب من اسرائيل اما احنا لو موت كل
الشعب الفلسطيني ما بتفرق معهم بس لله
وحده بس نشك همنا لربنا هي هي اواعي هي
اواعي بنت ابني هي ديره ابنه هي
اعيه اليوم الرابع بعد المئه الاطفال
والنساء هم النسبه الاعلى من الضحايا في
هذه الحرب ه الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح